what does the developer do day-to-day
well one thing that I had to learn when
I first started learning to code and I
still have to do today is creating user
stories
what are user stories well stay tuned to
find out now user story is a high-level
definition of empowerment for your
application that gives just enough
information so a developer can give it
estimation of how long it's going to
take to complete that task simply put a
user story describes how customer or
user is going to use your application so
in my experience an ITP M and K a
project manager will go out and
interview customer observe their
environment and see what types of
problems they're facing and then based
off that research they create a user
story so when I was first learning how
to code I had to play every single role
there was and developing a project so
that included being a project manager I
mean I had to create user stories on my
own now this helped me learn about agile
method methodology and it helped me to
understand how important it was to make
user stories and organizing a project
and visualizing the workflow of a user
so I encourage you to make user stories
for all the projects that you have now
that you're creating on your own before
you get a new job or as you're
transitioning into agile a team so the
syntax is simple it goes as a blank
which is a role I want to blink which
says what and then so that I can why why
do you want to do the what so let's say
that we're building an application for
dogs to meet other dogs in their city
let's call it sniffs and wolves now this
is kind of like meetup but for pet
owners and dogs so from a user's
perspective or customer aka a pet owner
I might want
for that for my pet to have a profile
page and this is a requirement so my
user story might go something like as a
pet owner that's the role I want my pet
to have a profile page that's the what
so that other pet owners can see my pet
before the initial meetup that's the one
or a good one might be that as a pet
owner I want my dog to have a profile
page so that I can share stories with
other pet owners so what do you think
about creating a user story so far does
it sound easy do you think you can put
it into your next project tell me a
little bit more about how you're gonna
employ this in the comments below now I
want to go a little bit deeper into why
it's so important to create user stories
so if you know who your target audience
is you know exactly what you're building
this application for this is your
opportunity to have a conversation with
them to figure out what they like what
their problems are and to build that
application so that they'll enjoy using
it and then it solves their problem now
if you don't know who your audience is
this is the opportunity to figure it out
this is the opportunity to create those
audiences and to understand who they are
and give your application towards them
instead of trying to please everybody
because fYI you can't also that last
part of your user story that says so
that that is something that should be
testable you want to have test subjects
later on and you want to have some words
to push them so say the sole that says
so that I can create stories and share
stories with other pet owners now when
I'm going through that as a developer or
as a user who's about to use this
application I should be able to see
somewhere that I can create those
stories and be able to share it with
other users it's always good to test
your applications so I also want to
discuss two terms that you might come in
contact with as you're diving more deep
into creating user stories of your own
and those terms are
and personas now epics are kind of like
user stories but they're way bigger and
you really can't complete them in the
two weeks that you're usually allotted
to finish a user story so an epic allows
you to get an overview of a feature
without committing to any details
they're really big and they're usually
broken down into user stories so say for
instance this was a book the epic might
be the title of the book
it's an overview it gives you an idea of
what the book is about and it doesn't
really give you too many details
whereas a user story would be the
chapters or even smaller they might be
the sections in those chapters so an
example of an epic might be to allow a
customer to manage his or her account
for their pet now as you can see this
epic doesn't say what type of user it is
it doesn't even tell you how yeah
they're gonna manage the account it's
just a broad overview of the feature and
it's going to be broken down into
various user stories so just know what
an epic is so the second term was
personas a lot of teams like to create
personas instead of roles when they're
creating user stories and personas are
fictional characters that you create
based off what you've learned about the
people who are going to be using
applications and those personas contain
a name a picture a relevant
characteristics and attitudes and they
have a goal that should be solved by
using your product so an example of a
persona would be Natalie she's 26 she's
an elementary school teacher and she
loves to run marathons
she loves pit bulls but she knows that
they have a bad rep so she would love to
help others fall in love with pit bulls
by giving them good experiences through
her own pit bull pets so that last part
about Natalie wanted to help people fall
in love with her pets through good
experiences that was a goal and that
goal should help me create epics which
should help you create user stories and
that epic should
like the fiction out here but your
application so now if you look back at
all the work we've done for this
fictitious there's an application called
sniffs and Wolf's you should be able to
have a great workflow to get you started
on creating this app so let's go through
them but persona Nathalie is 26 she is
an elementary school teacher and a
marathon runner
she loves pit bulls but knows they have
a bad rep she would love to help others
fall in love with pit bulls by having
good experiences with her pets the epic
to allow the customers to manage his own
account for their pet and finally the
user story as a pet owner I want to have
a profile for my pet so that I can share
stories before the get-together or with
a persona Nathalie a pet owner wants to
have a profile for her pet so that she
can share stories with other users and
they can fall in love with that pet
before the playdate so at this point you
should be able to create your own
personas epics and user stories for your
own application if you enjoy this video
give it a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe below also I'd love to see you
on Instagram and Twitter so join me by
taking a picture of your user stories
and acne or hashtag it coding like a
boss see you later